[Applause]
like this is Sparta was a line in the
script but it's really you that like
gave it that energy and life what
possessed well yeah because I was you
know we'd have that conversation you go
you know this is madness and now it's a
Madness this is Sparta boom I did a few
takes like that one a little
I I did I did one a little louder and
and then we then scene was done and they
were moving on the guys are kind of in
the camera away oh God no no no no no
wait wait wait wait wait because I
suddenly thought what about the wildness
in these men there's a wildness and a
surprise and it's like I can have that
conversation and then you go oh this is
who they really are so they bring it
back I'm with Madness this is Sparta
boom and and it's been cut and I turn
around and everybody was laughing behind
me because it just seemed so and I go
over to the director and I'm like that
was too much right it goes yeah but it
was awesome
[Applause]